sometimes the scp foundation needs to
get creative with how they go about
securing containing and protecting sadly
not everything can be solved with the
mobile task force or by locking it away
securely in a concrete chamber which
brings us to scp-2480
otherwise known by the nickname an
unfinished ritual when initially looking
through the file on scp-2480
the reader will immediately notice a
number of discrepancies throughout parts
of the entry have been crossed out
they've been struck through so they are
still readable not redacted completely
for the purposes of secrecy like many of
the details in other scp files first and
foremost
scp-2480 has been reclassified multiple
times first as safe then changed to the
infamous keter class but now it is
listed as far more ominous presumed
neutralized it's disconcerting because
presumed definitely leaves a lot of
questions so what exactly is scp-2480
scp-2480 is an area of dimensional
abnormality apparently created when an
occult ritual was interrupted in
november of 1952 hence the nickname of
an unfinished ritual the source of this
anomaly is located in a heavily forested
town somewhere near the coast of
massachusetts of course this state has
long been synonymous with many occult
happenings massachusetts famously being
home to a number of supposedly haunted
houses and sites of supernatural
activity and
scp-2480 is no exception seeming to fit
both of those criteria in order to keep
an eye on scp-2480 the foundation has
dispatched mobile task force epsilon 6
also codenamed the village idiots these
operatives are working undercover in the
surrounding area and nearby town keeping
watch for any sightings of anomalous
activity meanwhile another team mtf cy9
the abyss gazers are stationed nearby in
case any incidents should arise these
operatives have been authorized by the
scp foundation to employ the use of
lethal force on any and all anomalous
manifestations they should encounter
their directive is to destroy without
prejudice that sure sounds like a lot of
effort to secure something classed as
presumed neutralized the anomaly itself
is centered around an old massachusetts
house known as bodfell manor the manor
was once the home of a millionaire
industrialist by the name of cornelius p
bodfeld iii who died in 1952 at the age
of 86 and yes he died in the same year
that the ritual that created
scp-2480 took place but we're sure
that's probably just a coincidence right
interestingly during his life cornelius
bodfeld apparently had something of a
fascination with the occult it was
likely this interest that drew him to
creating a supernatural cult known as
adidium's wake little is known about
this organization and adidium's wake are
not part of the scp foundation's groups
of interest the list of other anomalous
groups that often rival the foundation
much like the anomaly itself they're
presumed neutralized the foundation
conducted a full-scale investigation
into bod filled manner and were able to
unearth more information about the
aforementioned cult fortunately
cornelius bodfeld kept a series of
meticulous and detailed journals as well
as photographs that give plenty of
insight into the activities of adidium's
wake unfortunately a lot of what they
got up to wasn't all that pleasant but
what did you expect from a group of
cultists adidium's wake would engage in
all kinds of depraved behavior some
that's better left to the imagination
what we can say is they'd often perform
ritualistic human sacrifice and indulge
in cannibalism and these are some of
their less unpleasant crimes on-site
personnel also uncovered sermon notes in
bodfell's journals detailing the cult
services and occult practices they also
found lists of the adidium's wake
members including local wealthy families
and respected politicians other
industrialists like cornelius bodfell
and even priests and other religious
figures the foundation had previously
been aware of adidium's wake but
initially dismissed the group as little
more than a decadent upper-class social
club not worthy of a full investigation
let's review shall we we have a
dimensional anomaly in a massachusetts
manner a cult obsessed with the
supernatural and some sort of ritual
that occurred in november
1952 but was interrupted before its
completion all parts of the same bizarre
and twisted puzzle but there's still a
piece yet to be uncovered
that missing piece the global occult
coalition who would have expected the
goc to rear their ugly heads around here
though it's worth mentioning that many
of the goc's member groups are occult in
nature so it probably shouldn't come
much as a surprise that they were
somehow involved in this case too it
goes without saying that the scp
foundation shares a complicated
relationship with this particular group
of interest each often disagreeing with
the other's methods occasionally the goc
and the scp foundation will put aside
their differences and act as allies
against large-scale threats like the
scarlet king but any alliance between
them is often uneasy and short-lived in
the case of scp-2480 the foundation were
first alerted to the anomaly's existence
when they decoded a goc distress signal
tracing its source to bodfell manor when
the investigative team arrived they
found deceased bodies littered
throughout the estate 36 corpses in
total each of these were confirmed to be
coalition operatives and the rest were
theorized to be dead members of
adidium's wake almost all the corpses
found at bodfell manor displayed signs
of anomalous causes of death some had
imploded
some disintegrated and others had their
bodies twisted into fatal new shapes at
first glance and given the goc's mission
to destroy the supernatural it looked as
if they had stormed in and interrupted
the adidium's wake cult while they were
right in the middle of performing a
ritual things went awry
scp-2480 was created and caused everyone
nearby to die horrifically surely that's
the whole story right well not quite as
it turns out while there were no
surviving goc operatives for the
foundation to interrogate the
investigative team were unable to
uncover documents related to the
operation in a nearby safe house used by
the goc much of the official
documentation was destroyed in an
attempted cover-up but a torn remainder
of a mission report was recovered in the
safe house's fireplace it was actually
the global occult coalition who had
initiated the ritual though its true
purpose was lost the foundation had
learned that the scp-2480 area had been
inadvertently created by the goc and
their heavy-handed approach to their
mission but why would an anti-occult
organization attempt a supernatural
ritual theories as to their intention
seem to point to the penultimate piece
of the puzzle sarkicism a widespread
religious cult that worships flesh and
disease the very existence of this
religion is viewed as a threat of
apocalyptic proportions by the scp
foundation sarkicism was initially
founded by the grand karcist ion but it
has since split into a number of smaller
subgroups over the millennia and among
those groups adidium's wake the goc
mission report fragment gathered by the
foundation describes the operative's
target to be grand karcist ion himself
he apparently cannot be directly
perceived so few actual descriptions of
his form exist it has been noted by some
to be humanoid in appearance at least
wearing what looks to be vestments
similar to a priest's and carrying a
staff ion is able to disappear and
reappear at will and possesses a
plethora of reality altering
capabilities the sarkic founder is able
to shift and reshape any organic
material as well as having the ability
to bend the very fabric of reality
around him while he may hold the
humanoid shape this entity is certainly
not human at least not any longer
functionally immortal grand carcissed
ion is noted to frequently exhibit signs
of malignant narcissism and megalomania
so now the story shifts the goc was
attempting to use adidium's wake to
summon ion in order for them to
eradicate the leader of the sarkic
religion the plan backfired though
scp-2480 was summoned and both the cult
and coalition operatives were killed end
of story right except there is one more
twist in this tale of cults and secrets
and that twist came from the last place
anyone would expect it came from inside
the scp foundation after scp-2480 was
created by the ritual at bodfell manor
site-13 was established in order to keep
the anomalous area contained you see if
the ritual was an atomic blast then
scp-2480 was both the crater and the
nuclear fallout from that blast except
instead of causing radiation sickness
the entire area around bodfell manor
became dimensionally unstable and prone
to anomalous occurrences overseeing site
13 was director simon oswalt a
foundation bureaucrat simon had been
selected for this duty thanks to his
distinct lack of imagination and because
the anomalous area of scp-2480 was
thought to be inconsequential at the
time in 1988 oswald failed to deliver
his regular report on scp-24
activity this was initially thought to
be a simple error except the foundation
couldn't get in contact with site-13 why
because the unfinished ritual hadn't
actually failed it wasn't unfinished the
goc had succeeded in summoning grand
karcist ion and simon oswalt had been
the one to discover this the founder of
sarkicism appeared to oswald who was
converted and turned against his
superiors at the scp foundation ion was
able to exert his influence over the
former bureaucrat swaying him to change
sides by showing oswalt a description in
the foundation's personnel dossier on
him that referred to him as a mirthless
dullard turning his back on the
foundation and pledging himself to
sarkicism simon oswalt was granted
anomalous abilities by grand karcist ion
oswald was given the power to control an
army of anomalous entities called
sarkites that he could summon through
the area of scp-20
grand karcist ion dubbed simon with a
new name karcist carvas and made him the
leader of his new army their goal was to
bring about the sarkic religion's ideal
the dawn of a new age of flesh that
would spell destruction for humanity
when the foundation lost contact with
site 13 they dispatched two agents to
investigate samuel rowe and sarah
valentine unaware of oswald's conversion
to sarkicism and his new purpose as
karcist karvas both agents were captured
by the sarkite creatures within scp-2480
the same monsters were also terrorizing
the nearby town replacing citizens and
sometimes even kidnapping and devouring
them another team was later sent in to
survey the area only to be killed or
replaced as well with only one survivor
dr khalidsto nervaez narvaez reported on
the situation to the o5 council and in
collaboration with the global occult
coalition the foundation launched an
assault against oswald the joint task
force of the two organizations were able
to neutralize the sarkites reclaiming
the area of scp-2480 and capturing simon
oswalt without his control the creatures
became directionless unable to so much
as eat or defend themselves grand
karcist ions plan had been thorted and
oswalt was taken back to an scp
foundation site though now under a new
name scp-2480-1
however during an operation at
containment area 14 oswald seemed to
suffer no effects from anesthetic or
surgical incision foundation researchers
were horrified to learn that oswalt no
longer possessed any internal organs
save for his brain heart and lungs the
rest of him was empty later he was
interrogated and began raving about
grand karcist ions so much that the
doctor questioning oswald attempted to
attack him breaking free of his
restraints simon oswalt amputated both
of the doctor's arms before he was
recontained by guards since then the
area of
scp-2480 has been mostly quiet but it
still remains under the foundation's
close watch just in case any anomalous
happenings start up again but if you're
planning a tour of the many haunted old
houses of massachusetts we'd recommend
maybe avoiding bodfell manor just to be
safe now go check out
scp-1730 what happened to site 13 and
scp-4999 someone to watch over us tale
for more supernatural tales from the scp
foundation